[Music]
no matter how old we were at that time
we were all happy to discover this new
Disney Channel sitcom when her little
sister Charlie was born
Teddy decided to film a video diary that
she was going to watch when she would be
older
however Charlie will have to wait until
she has a grown-up before watching the
video because Disney hid some things
that were really inappropriate for
children just wait until you hear more
about what the original story was
supposed to be it was really dramatic if
you love good luck charlie as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you dark secrets good luck
charlie tried to hide the gay couple in
January 2014
signe surprises viewers with the first
gay couple on their channel in the
episode Bob and Amy we're talking about
who was coming over for a playdate with
their daughter Charlie they both met the
little tailor but Amy says that the name
of his mom was Susan while bob said that
he met his mother named Cheryl who was
going to come to their house do they
invite
kids named Taylor when the doorbell rang
they were surprised to see that Taylor
actually had two mothers it was great to
see diversity on TV as the LGBT
community was finally represented but
unfortunately not everyone agrees with
us many people thought that it was
inappropriate to show a gay couple in a
sitcom for kids Jay said that they
wouldn't be watching the show again
because of that the anti-gay group 1
Million Moms even wrote that just
because something may be legal or
because some aren't choosing a lifestyle
doesn't make it morally correct but
Disney will never think that it was a
bad decision a spokesperson told TV
Guide that the storyline was developed
under the consultancy of child
development experts and community
advisors so you don't have to worry your
child can still watch good luck charlie
the only thing that will happen is that
they'll quickly understand that love is
love no matter who your soulmate is the
threat it is impossible to not love me
Attalla rico the actress who played the
role of Charlie in the popular sitcom
she is extremely cute she's really funny
and she's always called Mia is the child
that everyone wants to have in their
family no matter how old the other kids
are and if you love her as much as we do
you can also follow her on Instagram
her mom Claire's been posting pictures
of her for years and we love to see her
growing up unfortunately being popular
also comes with a lot of haters and the
the worst was a man threatened and
harassed the young actress who was 5
years old at that time by telling her
terrible things they even sent a picture
to show what they would do to her who is
so frightening that we don't even want
to repeat it
her mom quickly reported it to the
authorities it may started investigate
however law enforcement officials said
that their threat analysis unit always
keeps their threat investigation
findings and recommendations
confidential because often the people
who make shreds read the media coverage
they receive Disney had no comment about
this situation at least we are happy to
hear that Mia is now safe and it didn't
keep her from making the world smile by
posting more pictures on social media
the child actor children are not
supposed to work they are supposed to
have fun with their family and friends
play games and go to school this is why
many people are not comfortable with the
idea that child actors have to work many
hours a day for a long time and as Mia
Tallarico was only around one year when
she started working on good luck charlie
many people thought that she missed an
part of her childhood after all she was
too young to make that decision and she
wasn't prepared for a big role that
would last four seasons moreover being
really popular at a very young age can
have terrible consequences as we could
see when Mia received threats but don't
worry there are many rules that
producers have to follow if they want to
work with children 15% of earnings that
the child actor is transferred to an
account to be held in trust until the
minor is 80 performers under 16 need to
be accompanied by a responsible person
and there is always under contract and
the employer also has to provide time
and facilities for the education of
child performers who can't work for too
many hours now that he is older she
looks more beautiful than ever
and we can still see a big smile on her
face we guess that she liked being an
actress after all be inappropriate jokes
but we loved the most about good luck
charlie is that the whole family loved
watching it including the parents
grown-ups like to be surprised by some
inappropriate jokes that their kids
wouldn't understand however many people
think that they have gone too far for
example when they were talking about
making sure that the parents would not
make another baby they looked at Bob who
replied that making babies is a team
effort and they didn't understand then
when they talked about doing it on their
wedding day they said that what they did
was getting married Amy how stiff Bob
had the talk with Gabe and he replied
that he doesn't even have the talk with
PJ and will never forget when Mel pull
down his pants and underwear at the
ballgame and when PJ was wearing nothing
but a snowboard and don't think that the
grown-ups are just two fruits even tini
complain that they don't want their
little siblings to watch good luck
charlie because they think that it is
inappropriate for children this show is
supposed to be suitable for people over
8 years old but many people argue that
you should be at least 16 years old to
watch this we don't think that young
kids understood any of these jokes
anyway but their parents are the only
ones you can know if they are mature
enough to watch this show the bad kids
this time the kids are not complaining
about the inappropriate jokes but the
parents have much more reason to think
that this show is not suitable for
children that's because the four kids in
the family terrible role model according
to them for example most episodes show
the kids lying with no consequences and
being disrespectful to their parents and
other adults they also use each other
for selfish purposes for example when PJ
was delivering chicken he said that his
mom was in the hospital and this is why
he had to take care of his little sister
Charlie while working the mom even
played the game in exchange for food
moreover when Charlie was arrested for
stealing a pair of sunglasses the three
kids just destroyed the store to escape
instead of waiting for the police
officers to arrive and explain what
really happened those parents were
disappointed by the show saying that
kids are always smarter than their
parents and also believed that it taught
kids to be mouthy and disrespectful but
we are all wondering how a sitcom can be
relatable for kids if the characters
don't talk and act like them most kids
didn't listen to their parents before
the show anyway we just hoped that
Charlie will be mature enough when she
watches the video diaries that her
sister prepared for her but anyway it
wins me a bat for her to become just
like
teddie the audience did you know that
some scenes of the TV series were filmed
in front of an audience this is why we
hear people laughing during this show it
seems like an incredible experience but
unfortunately it wasn't as good as you
might think that's because a woman
claimed that a Disney Channel comedian
repeatedly spanked her with his hands in
front of her two children and a live
studio audience
Kelly Rodriguez and two other audience
members were asked to go onstage to do
their best silly dance to YMCA by the
Village People this was when Ron Pearson
started spanking her in front of
everyone
she never consented to this Ron never
asked if he could do this and he didn't
even stop until she turned around to
tell him that he shouldn't do that then
Pearson requested a kiss on the cheek
when Rodriguez obliged he turned his
face so she would kiss him on the lips
the poor woman didn't want the comedian
to get away with that so she filed a
lawsuit she then decided to seek public
damages for assault battery negligence
negligent hiring negligent retention of
unfit employees negligent supervision
negligent training negligent infliction
of emotional distress and intentional
infliction of emotional distress we
think that Ron Pearson will regret this
forever and this is a good thing no one
should have to write to touch a woman if
she doesn't want to and Kelly did the
best thing by defending herself
the boys we heard kids complaining about
the inappropriate jokes and parents
saying that the four kids were some of
the worst role models but there is one
other thing that everyone complained
about teddy was too into boys the first
episode didn't give her a good
reputation all she wanted was a kiss and
she complained when she had to take care
of her family even if her parents didn't
want her to go on a date that night
later she fell in love with many guys in
one episode describing the love of her
life as simply cute and named Brandon
because that's all she knew about him
that's not how love works young lady
some parents complained that their
daughter doesn't need a boy crazy
teenager as their role model they were
shocked that this kid show was all about
Teddy getting her first kiss meeting hot
guys going to parties and even lying
to her parents to get that it didn't
help when fiction became reality when
actors Shane Harper and bridgit mendler
started dating but even though many
people thought that teddy was a bad role
model many other parents argued that she
is just like any other teenager falling
in love is part of growing up and Teddy
has to go through these kinds of
experiences if young girls want to feel
like they are similar to her the love as
we said previously bridgit mendler and
Shane Harper were not only a couple on
the screen but also in real life however
they didn't always like each other
their on-screen relationship was pretty
rocky and it was worse in real life
that's because the actress thought that
Shane was annoying when they first met
she was 16 when she met him but he was
only 15 so she then called herself a
cougar actually Shane was only two
months younger than her but that was
enough to make her feel like she was too
good when she finally dated him she
admitted that it was lame for her to
think that but what changed her mind
Brigitte said that two years later they
were just in the same friend group for a
while and he were down she thinks that
the one thing that made it work is
persistence
bridgett said that chivalry will always
exist and a guy should fight and wait
for a girl we are glad that Shane never
gave up because the two looked too cute
together
however relationships don't last forever
and the two actors split up in November
2015 he was the one who inspired her
song Atlantis which is really different
from what we usually hear from a Disney
star she describes this feeling by
saying that she was overwhelmed by
emotional numbness like a whole city
overcome by waves and dumped in the
ocean only people that we really love
have the power to do that so we can
believe that their relationship used to
be truly important to her the original
story this one is nothing but a rumor
but it is so interesting that we
couldn't not tell you about this people
believe that the original story of good
luck charlie was not as beautiful as you
might think it was called love teddy in
story the teenager had everything she
ever wanted popularity of boyfriend and
good grades but then everything changed
she spent the night with a man that she
didn't want to see ever again
since he/she realized that she was
pregnant her parents were furious when
they found out about that but being
strong Christians they decided that she
needed to keep the babies they forced
her to stay at home and be homeschooled
to save the family from embarrassment
then when the baby was born
Teddy's parents pretended that they were
the biological parents and forbidden any
close contact for Teddy and her babies
this is why the teenager decided to
write letters to her child to stay in
contact with her it would always end
with your loving mother teddy
however there is no proof that anyone
working for Disney ever thought about
that
this theory just became popular when
people started writing fan fiction
inspired by this news story no matter
what we think that we really prefer good
luck charlie love teddy would never be
suitable for Disney Channel anyway the
end why do all the best things always
come to an end after four great seasons
we finally had to say goodbye to Charlie
and her family in 2014
teddy was going to college and didn't
have time to film her video diary
anymore but we don't think that this is
a good reason to end the show after all
fans wanted to see more and we wouldn't
mind seeing what happens in college or
watching Gabe's starting his own video
diary we think that Disney cancelled the
show
simply because they tend to do this
after they hit the 100 episode mark but
why are they doing that we should not
forget the channels make money mostly
from advertisers and if fewer people are
watching the show after four years they
can't make as much money as they did
before so even if good luck charlie was
one of the best TV series in 2012 with 3
million total viewers per episode there
weren't as many people watching after 4
years
moreover as the channel puts it all good
things
sometimes you don't have any other ideas
and it's better to cancel the shows and
to create more episodes that no one will
like and ruin the reputation of the show
but no matter what we think that good
luck Charlie deserved a spinoff what is
the dark secret that shocked you the
most don't be shy to tell us what it is
in the comments section down below we
love hearing from you and that's it for
dark secret good luck charlie tried to
hide for more stories like this make
sure you watch Tim Jesse dark secrets
Disney tried to hide thanks for watching
[Music]